[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the alleged victim was quote
deep in conversation with acquaintances
at a crowded Manhattan night spot and
did not notice the figure to her right
on a red velvet couch until she recalls
his fingers slid under her miniskirt
moved up her inner thigh and touched her
vagina through her underwear the Harvey
Weinstein nightmare is seemingly
unending and it's evil even touches
politics tangentially but of course the
man on the red velvet couch was not
Harvey Weinstein but according to former
model Kristin Anderson it was Donald
Trump I'll go backstage before a show
before and everyone's getting dressed
and ready and everything else and you
know no men are anywhere and I'm allowed
to go in because I'm the owner and
therefore I'm inspecting it they're
standing there with no clothes is
everybody okay and you see these
incredible looking women and so I sort
of get away with things like that the
Harvey Weinstein crisis and the crises
rolling out behind it in film and TV may
reveal an epidemic but of course the
entertainment mogul describing how he
got away with staring at the naked women
backstage the young naked women was not
Harvey Weinstein but was by his own
admission Donald Trump after another
alleged victim revealed that she was
pushed against the wall and the
perpetrator had forced his tongue into
her mouth the alleged perpetrator later
told his apologist quote take a look you
take a look look at her you tell me what
you think the dismissal by his
apologists his enablers for decades of
how Harvey Weinstein exploited his power
against women is its own scandal but of
course the man who dismissed his accuser
by implying she wasn't good-looking
enough for him to have attacked her
wasn't Harvey Weinstein it was according
to the victim Donald Trump after the
other victim one of the other victims
one of at least two dozen self revealed
victims said he lifted up the airplane
armrest that separated them and grabbed
her breasts and tried to put his hand up
her skirt the perpetrator told a
different group of his apologists quote
believe me she would not be my first
choice
Harvey Weinstein no of course not
Donald Trump but the Republicans press
forward to make Weinstein and some sort
of symbol of the Democrats ignoring the
minor difference between a partisan
donor and say a president ignoring even
the Donald Trump himself donated at
least a million dollars to Republican
campaigns and PACs and causes and just
on that front is at best Weinstein's
equivalent and Kellyanne Conway speaks
with a straight face about Trump
empowering women when she was his
campaign manager when the [ __ ] grabber
tape came out and Trump pretended it was
locker room talk instead of the
soundtrack to his decades of lechery and
Sean Spicer repeatedly tweets about
Democrats not distancing themselves from
Weinstein but doesn't say one word about
Trump and when Sebastian Gorka goes on
Fox News to address the Weinstein
fallout and says quote the left in the
media love their scumbags it's really
that simple
let us call a spade a spade and
recognize that the Republicans elected
their scumbag president and to this day
continued to support their scumbag and
about Weinstein and money and supposed
Democratic hypocrisy now The Weinstein
Company which Harvey Weinstein will at
worst be suing for millions of dollars
in severance it has announced it is to
be saved financially by an infusion of
cash from a company owned by Tom Barrack
who may be the closest friend in the
business world to Donald Trump
they say Harvey Weinstein is a monster
and his company enabled him but let that
company die hell no this is business and
just to Ratchet it up just to make this
ultimate false equivalent somehow more
fraudulent somehow more outrageous
somehow more disgusting Trump has
proclaimed this national character
counts week you want to play the false
equivalence game Republicans that Harvey
Weinstein is somehow as bad and as
important as Donald Trump fine
the Democrats have repudiated Harvey
Weinstein they've given Weinstein his
money back or given his money away
Weinstein has been removed from his job
Weinstein has been removed from any
political influence in this nation
Weinstein has literally fled this
country if the evil of Harvey Weinstein
is somehow as meaningful as the evil of
Donald Trump if the Republicans are
gonna lecture our country about moral
turpitude and protecting predators the
Republicans must now repudiate Donald
Trump they must give Trump his money
back or give his money away they must
remove Trump from his job they must
remove Trump from any political
influence in this nation Trump must
literally be forced to flee this country
because character counts resist remove
piece the book based on these
commentaries has now been published as I
edited the manuscript and then read the
audiobook I confess I was a little
surprised it's pretty good and I was
even more surprised just how much of
this crap I had forgotten your patronage
is appreciated